Before I introduce the fundamental law,
I've got to define a few terms.
Let's start with information ratio.
So recall, the return on our portfolio
for a particular day is equal to
the market component of the return,
which is beta for that portfolio,
times the return on the market for
that day, plus this residual return.
Another way to look at that is to say
that this component of the return
is due to the market, and this component
is due to the skill of the fund manager.
Remember, alpha is about skill.
Now, we want to focus
on the skill component.
In other words, what is the fund
manager bringing to the table?
And we can calculate the Sharpe ratio,
essentially, of this component,
just like we can calculate the Sharpe
ratio of an entire portfolio.
But we can focus on this skill
component, and essentially the Sharpe
ratio of this skill component
is the information ratio.
It works like this.
So the information ratio is
the mean of all of the alpha
components divided by the standard
deviation of the alpha components.
So this is our reward component.
That's our risk component.
And by the way, this is calculated
by looking back historically
at the daily values of alpha.
And we take the mean and the standard
deviation of them over time.
You can find these by finding beta for
the portfolio, calculating what
the market return component was for
each day, and then the difference
is this residual or skill.
So that's how you can
compute historically
the value of this information ratio.
Now by the way, this information ration
applies in many different cases,
not just in this fundamental law case.
People use information
ratio as a measure
of manager performance all the time.
It's fair to say that information
ratio is essentially a Sharpe ratio
of excess return,
this part that's due to skill.